auch dem zauber des anfangs ein ganzes
buch gewidmet
die kunst der sprachlichen überwältigung
beherrscht macht am wittener mühelos
seit 25 jahren report ihr tier für den
zürcher tages anzeiger
rund 6.000 artikel hatte geschrieben
dass heißt auch rund 6000 mal anfangen
eine beschleunigung von moment besitzt
eine macht - flugzeug man reist trifft
und das ist immer auf der zeitachse
stellen oder und ich glaube dass es mir
immer mit großer energie denn passiert
ist es so wichtig die richtige haltung
zu bieten als buch ein reicher kosmos
der persönlichen anfänge das erste wort
der erste schultag die erste sekunde des
jahres das erste mal aufhören zu rauchen
die erste yogastunde da bin ich wenn ich
mit aller ernsthaftigkeit und ich hab
gestern nach der ziele das russian
arbeitet die nyt anders machen wäre das
mal ausdrücken ohne anfang ist kein
weiterkommen auf das kurze glück des
geschrieben haben zeigt die lange hölle
des schreibens
der anfang als tägliche herausforderung
ersatz überraschen
das ist ein witz das steigert die
spannung ob soft entwicklung gut
nachvollziehen
1983 der junge journalist schreibt seine
erste plattenkritik die leidenschaft für
die musik bleibt die nervosität vor
jedem interview übrigens auch
das bekenntnis hafte ist ihm ein gräuel
trotzdem erzählte immer weiter von
seinen anfängen auch im bundeshaus
am ersten april 1998 kurz nach neun uhr
morgens betrat ich das bundeshaus zum
ersten mal nicht als tourist sondern als
korrespondent hans mesch motto in der
maschine kann ich mit gutem gewissen
sagen dass ich sehr wenig von uns
politik stand davon vergessen zu
schneiden hier gilt je länger man
anfänger bleibt desto besser
interessiert sich für eine sache wo
profis vollkommen neue und mehr
überrascht vor vorgang wo liegt mit
großer erfahrung
so lange liegt findet das ist nicht
immer wieder warnt vor zu seinen hit
vergessen ist wohl nicht tun die nach
obi und thomas ist unser roadster 26 im
berühmten 786 see und den hatten wir der
politik vor gericht und er nicht mehr
stinkt sagt addio la mode und es ist gut
drauf und bundesrat mit dem weg zur
pressekonferenz ein dass sowohl in der
schweiz möglich er schreibt über anfänge
und meint begegnungen mit anderen mit
sich selbst am flughafen zum beispiel
vom moment an wo man den flugplatz
betritt bis zum moment da das flugzeug
abhebt wird man schrittweise zum
zeitlichen räumlichen gefangenen zitiert
nach und vielfach und frischer wenn sind
all die kontrolle mit immer mühe darum
erwartet erwartet immer die stimme wo
ein umfaller und ich merke dass ich
obwohl ich abflug eine neue station
anstrich wird bremst immer mehr und
immer mithalten und im moment seine
anthologie der anfänger präzise
beobachtungen der alltäglichen
absurditäten
so wartet am flughafen nicht die große
freiheit sondern die mobile
gefangenschaft
foto patrick seeger genau das gefühl
beschreibt das meine ich dass es
juni
es sich ausgeht